[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Jana
pareigis einen schönen Sonntagabend
wünsche ich Ihnen Wintersport und mehr
gibt es von Sven Voß auch von mir einen
schönen guten Abend und unter anderem
diese Themen haben wir für Sie
Allianz fehlen die Panzer Bundeskanzler
Scholz wird bei weiteren Staaten dafür
Leopard Panzer für die Ukraine zu
liefern
die Luft ist raus die USA schießen einen
mutmaßlichen chinesischen spionageballon
ab und die diplomatischen Beziehungen
eine neue Krise
und goldene Zeiten im Eiskanal Francesco
Friedrich holt den WM-Titel im
viererbock
[Musik]
zusammen mit Partnerstaaten will die
Bundesregierung kleopath 2 Panzer an die
Ukraine liefern so der Plan es fehlen
jedoch noch von einigen genaue Zusagen
die Allianz ist also bisher nicht
komplett
es bestehe ein Konsens mit dem
ukrainischen Präsidenten selensky dass
die gelieferten Kriegswaffen nicht für
Angriffe auf russische Staatsgebiet
eingesetzt werden sagte Kanzler Scholz
in der Bild am Sonntag Klaus Brodbeck
über die Panzerlieferungen
das hier ist der erste Leopard 2 A4 eine
ältere Version aber immerhin auf dem Weg
in Richtung Ukraine heute Verladen auf
einer Luftwaffenbasis im kanadischen
Halifax andere tun sich schwerer Spanien
etwa verspricht ebenfalls alte Versionen
die aber erst überholt werden müssen
Monate kann das dauern Portugal geht es
ähnlich
wir arbeiten derzeit mit Deutschland
zusammen an der Logistik für Ersatzteile
damit wir die Panzer die nicht bereit
sind einsatzfähig machen können
der
spd-generalsekretär im Gespräch mit dem
heute journal kritis man hat ja in den
letzten Wochen teilweise den Eindruck
kriegen können alle weltwolle liefern
nur die Bundesrepublik Deutschland nicht
jetzt sehen wir Deutschland macht eine
konkrete Zusage es wird auch tatsächlich
eine Panzer Kompanie geliefert und
plötzlich ist es sehr leise geworden um
uns herum holen hat dem Vorfeld Druck
aufgebaut will moderne Leo 2a 6 liefern
lässt nun jedoch offen wann und wie
viele dafür so Polens
Verteidigungsminister am Freitag in Kiew
habe die Ausbildung ukrainische Soldaten
bereits begonnen auf Twitter appelliert
heute Kiews Vize Außenminister Melnik an
alle Länder die über Leopard Kampfpanzer
verfügen ohne weitere Verzögerung ihren
Beitrag zu leisten um die Befreiung
aller besetzten Gebiete im Jahr 2023 zu
ermöglichen politischer Druck dem der
Bundeskanzler weiter begegnen will wie
zuvor überlegt vertrauen Sie mir
vertrauen Sie der Regierung wir werden
weiter sorgfältig abgewogen und im
Einklang mit unseren Verbündeten Handeln
Leoparden für die Ukraine sie kommen
aber langsam
dann jetzt im Osten der Ukraine dauern
die schweren Kämpfe an und auch die Lage
an der Front im Nordosten bleibt für die
ukrainische Armee schwierig in der Stadt
Brake schlugen russische Raketen ein sie
trafen auch Wohngebäude mehrere Menschen
wurden verletzt der Beschuss zerstörte
außerdem Teile der Universität im
historischen Zentrum der Stadt
wegen zunehmender Schwierigkeiten bei
der Unterbringung von geflüchteten in
Deutschland haben Länder Kommunen und
Oppositionen einen Gipfel mit dem Bund
gefordert im ZDF kündigte
bundesinnenministerin Feser nun
gemeinsame Gespräche an ich sehe dass
nach wie vor Handlungsbedarf besteht und
deswegen werde ich jetzt wieder alle
Beteiligten zu einem erneuten
flüchtlingsgipfel zu mir ins Haus
einladen ich werde das diese Woche noch
rausschicken die Einladung weil ich
glaube wir müssen in einer gemeinsamen
Kraftanstrengung alles dafür tun die
Kommunen zu entlasten und das ganze
Interview mit der bundesinnenministerin
gibt es gleich nach unserer Sendung in
Berlin direkt
seid ihr am Himmel entdeckt wurde sorgt
dafür politische Aufregung jetzt hat die
US-Luftwaffe den mutmaßlichen
spionageballon aus China vor der Küste
von South Carolina abgeschossen die
Trümmer sollen untersucht werden all das
hat die Krise zwischen Washington und
Peking nochmal verschärft aus den USA
berichtet Johannes Hano eine Woche bei
der chinesische Ballon über
us-staatsgebiet unterwegs zog seine
Kreise rund um amerikanische
Militäreinrichtungen kontrolliert
gesteuert wie das
US-Verteidigungsministerium gestern
mitteilte als der Ballon vor der Küste
South caroliners aufs Meer hinausflug
dann der Abschuss über amerikanischen
Hoheitsgewässern mit einer Rakete
abgefeuert von einem Kampfjet ich habe
ihn den Befehl gegeben ihn abzuschießen
schon am Mittwoch sie haben mir gesagt
sie warten um es an einem sicheren Ort
zu tun
vor dem Abschuss wurden Luftraum und
Schifffahrtswege gesperrt man wollte
verhindern dass die schweren Trümmer
größeren Schaden anrichten entlang der
Küste beobachten viele Schaulustige die
Attacke das chinesische
Verteidigungsministerium reagierte auf
den Abschuss empört
die Vereinigten Staaten haben unser
ziviles Drohnen Luftschiff mit Gewalt
angegriffen das war eine offensichtliche
Überreaktion wir bringen unseren
vehementen Protest gegen die US-Aktion
zum Ausdruck und behalten uns vor
daraufhin angemessener Weise zu
reagieren
die Frage die sich viele Stellen ist
warum China den Ballon überhaupt
geschickt hat den Aufklärung ist auch
aus dem All mit Satelliten sicher und
vor allem legal möglich es wird jetzt
vermutet dass China die beiden Regierung
austesten wollte denn schon unter der
Präsidentschaft Donald Trumps hatte ich
China drei Balance geschickt und die
wurden nicht abgeschossen in den
nächsten Tagen will das US-Militär die
Überreste des Balance Bergen und
analysieren der Abschluss aber so viel
steht fest wird das sowieso schon
angespannte Verhältnis der beiden
Supermächte weiter belasten
Ex Verfassungsschutz chefmaßen hat das
Ultimatum verstreichen lassen eine
freiwillig aus der CDU auszutreten es
endete heute um 12 Uhr nun will die
Parteien Aufschlussverfahren einleiten
Maßen hat nach Auskunft der CDU aber
noch bis Donnerstag Gelegenheit sich
schriftlich zu äußern bei Twitter
Sprache heute von einer Schmutzkampagne
vorgeworfen werden ihm völkische und
antisemitische Äußerungen
mit einem Trauergottesdienst haben
hunderte Abschied von den beiden Opfern
der Messe Attacke von Brokstedt genommen
an dem Gottesdienst in Neumünster nahmen
auch Bundeskanzler Scholz und
Schleswig-Holsteins Ministerpräsident
Günther teil
vor elf Tagen hatte ein 33-jähriger
Palästinenser in einem Regionalzug zwei
junge Menschen getötet und weitere
verletzt der mehrfach vorbestrafte Mann
war nur eine Woche zuvor aus der
Untersuchungshaft freigelassen worden
in Chile wüten derzeit verheerende
Waldbrände mindestens 23 Menschen sind
bereits ums Leben gekommen
besonders betroffen sind drei Regionen
südlich der Hauptstadt Santiago de Chile
die Regierung hat den
katastrophenzustand ausgerufen hunderte
Menschen mussten in Sicherheit gebracht
werden Pablo
unerbittlich fressen sich die Flammen
voran noch immer sind dutzende Feuer
außer Kontrolle fast 14.000 Hektar Wald
haben sie seit Mittwoch schon zerstört
und die Zahl der Toten steigt mit jedem
Tag viele Menschen haben alles verloren
ich habe mein Haus nur mit Kleidern die
ich anhatte verlassen ich habe mir
Schuhe und eine Strumpfhose geschnappt
und bin raus es blieb keine Zeit eine
Brandschutzmauer oder so zu errichten
die Windgeschwindigkeit änderte sich
sehr schnell plötzlich brannte alles es
ging alles sehr sehr schnell
die genaue Ursache ist noch immer unklar
sieben Menschen wurden inzwischen wegen
möglicher Brandstiftung festgenommen
fest steht Temperaturen von bis zu 40
Grad Celsius und starke Winde haben für
die rasante Ausbreitung gesorgt die
Regierung bittet um internationale Hilfe
mit mehreren Regierungen gesprochen
damit sie uns dort unterstützen wo wir
bislang mit privaten Unternehmen
zusammenarbeiten
zahlreiche Länder haben schon Hilfe
zugesagt auch in den nächsten Tagen wird
der erhoffte Wetterumschwung wohl
ausbleiben die Temperaturen bleiben hoch
Regen ist nicht in Sicht
wir kommen jetzt zum Sport mit der
bob-wm in St Moritz und die an der
richtigen Erfolgsgeschichte Sven das
kann man wohl sagen Francesco Friedrich
ist einfach nicht zu schlagen zum
fünften Mal nacheinander wird der
bob-pilot aus Pirna Weltmeister im
großen Schlitten dabei machten es der
32-Jährige und seine Crew
zwischenzeitlich sogar noch mal spannend
der Sachse gewinnt insgesamt schon seit
zwölftes WM Gold dank Triumphen noch im
zweierbox Francesco Friedrich profitiert
von einem Fahrfehler des dritten Hall
vor ihm der ACT einmal richtig an nach
Problemen in seinem dritten Lauf
erwischt Friedrich auf der Natur Eisbahn
in St Moritz in seinem vierten Lauf fast
die ideale Linie mit Thorsten marges an
Bauer und Alexander Schüler baut er
seinen Vorsprung auf komfortablen 69-100
Sekunden aus die zeitgleichen und Briten
holen Silber seit 9 Jahren hat Friedrich
damit immer Gold gewonnen beim
Saisonhöhepunkt Olympia oder WM
und in der Nordischen Kombination holt
Julian Schmid den Weltcupsieg in seiner
Heimatstadt Oberstdorf nach einer
starken Aufholjagd
Julian Schmid legt mit 134 Metern auf
der Schanze und Rang drei nach dem
Springen eine aussichtsreiche Grundlage
für seinen Erfolg es kurz vor dem Ziel
holt der Oberstdorfer auf seiner
Heimstrecke mit dem Norweger of the blue
und Weltmeister Lampart aus Österreich
den führenden Franz Josef real,- der mit
rund 1 Minute Vorsprung auf die Strecke
gegangen war im Schloss Sprint auf der
Zielgeraden gelingt Schmied mit einem
Kraftakt sein Meisterstück 3 Sieg in
seiner Karriere allesamt in dieser
Saison Schmied in Top Form zweieinhalb
Wochen vor der WM
im ersten Sonntagsspiel der
Fußball-Bundesliga gewann Bremen in
Stuttgart mit 2:0 der VfB bleibt in
diesem Jahr weiter siegloss und steht
nun auf Platz 16 und hoffenheims Trainer
Andre Breitenreiter sollen darüber
einstimmenden Medienberichten vor dem
ausstehen das 2:5 in Bochum war das 10
sieglose Spiel in Folge für breiten
Reiter und die abstiegsbedrohte TSG
Handball DHB Pokal nach Flensburg Lemgo
Lemgo und den Rhein-Neckar Löwen hat
sich auch der SC Magdeburg für die
Finalrunde qualifiziert der deutsche
Meister behielt in einem packenden Spiel
die Nerven und besiegte den
Titelverteidiger THW Kiel mit 35 zu 34
nach Verlängerung
und das war es vom sportjahren danke
schauen wir noch wie das Wetter wird
morgen fällt in der Mitte und im Süden
etwas Schnee in den Tälern auch Regen
sonst zeigt sich auch mal die Sonne die
Höchsttemperatur liegt zwischen -1 und
plus 7 Grad
annegalinek begrüßt Sie hier um 21:45
Uhr zum heute journal morgen fällt in
der Mitte und im Süden etwas Schnee in
den Tälern auch Regen sonst zeigt sich
auch mal die Sonne die Höchsttemperatur
liegt zwischen -1 und plus 7 Grad